[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct ravi de vous retrouver
l'actualité ce soir c'est se déplacement
présidentielle au large de Saint-Nazaire
Emmanuel Macron a inauguré la première
ferme en mer française 80 éoliennes
offshore un chantier titanesque 10 ans à
voir le jour l'éolien conspu et pendant
la présidentielle et donc de retour en
grâce mais il faut accélérer comment le
retard français est-il rattrapable c'est
notre grand débat ce soir avec nos
invités il a vu le Parti socialiste Soto
détruire sous ses yeux quand il
travaillait à l'Elysée il était aux
premières loges quand François Hollande
a décidé de ne pas se représenter depuis
il est resté de gauche malgré pas mal
d'états d'âmes il raconte tout ça dans
un livre personnel mais pas désespéré
Gaspard Gantzer et notre grand témoin ce
soir enfin trois affranchis trois
parties pris Isabelle Lasserre revient
ce soir sur le choc en Russie après
l'annonce de Vladimir Poutine de
mobiliser 300 000 hommes dans la guerre
en U la politique avec Elsa mondingava
vers un atterrissage en douceur sur les
retraites et puis un nouveau visage
l'enseignant et essayiste Yanis roder
qui va revenir chaque semaine avec des
histoires d'école sur le terrain voilà
pour le menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs la France aura peu de
centrale nucléaire pour se chauffer cet
hiver mais elle pourra compter pour la
première fois sur ces éoliennes en mer
c'est la fin d'un gigantesque chantier
inauguré ce matin vous le voyez par
Emmanuel Macron au large de
Saint-Nazaire le premier parc éolien
offshore de France entre en vigueur à la
fin de l'année le gouvernement s'engage
à aller vite et elle est plus loin plus
fort sur les énergies renouvelables mais
se donne-t-il vraiment les moyens de
rattraper notre immense retard en la
matière bonsoir Sylvain Maillard bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous sur LCP
porte-parole du groupe Renaissance le
parti présidentiel est député de Paris
bonsoir Loïc Prudhomme bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous député la France
insoumise de Gironde membre de la nupes
bonsoir Michel giorget et merci d'être
là délégué général de France énergie
éolienne qui représente les
professionnels de la filière et c'est un
gisement d'emploi industriel
considérable pour notre pays bonsoir
Franck l'ouvrier
à distance avec nous depuis La Baule
avec une petite maquette d'éolienne et
un cocorico français merci d'être d'être
là parmi nous on a besoin forcément de
l'éclairage d'un maire de terrain un
maire d'une ville du littoral de notre
belle côte française enfin l'expert
énergie fuck vin Nguyen va nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant il
suit les politiques publiques énergies
Europe pour l'institut Jacques Delors
avant de vous donner la parole messieurs
on plante le décor comme chaque soir
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à tous si j'ai bien compris le grand
méchant loup c'était l'éolien pendant la
présidentielle c'est devenu le grand
gentil
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir si j'ai
bien compris Myriam la France inaugure
donc son premier parc éolien en mer et
vous me connaissez je suis pas le
dernier à pousser un petit cocorico
quand l'occasion se présente franchement
quand on est bon en France autant être
cher sauf que là j'hésite un petit peu
je sais pas pourquoi je veux
le côté Chauvin là non non là ce qui me
gêne c'est que ça serait carrément
ridicule de lâcher un cocorico sur ce
sujet je vous résume la situation en
France on a en gros 3000 km de côte ça
change pas mais on va dire plus ou moins
3 km de côte et donc on a le premier
potentiel d'énergie éolienne dans
l'Union européenne mais qu'est-ce qu'on
fait de ce potentiel alors on va sur
Wikipédia regarde le classement la
proportion de l'éolien dans les mix
énergétiques donc en France on est voilà
17e moins de 10%, ça veut dire qu'on a
le plus fort potentiel éolien dans
l'Union européenne mais on sait pas
l'utiliser quoi alors il faut dire que
une partie de la classe politique c'est
beaucoup beaucoup proposé à l'éolien
c'est vrai donc encore récemment vous
l'aviez dit pendant la campagne
présidentielle Marine Le Pen dans la
dernière ligne droite elle avait proposé
ça elle avait dit bah je vous rappelle
regardez on va démonter toutes ces
éoliennes qui vous embêtent et puis on
sait que celui qui a vraiment été en
première ligne très longtemps c'est
Xavier Bertrand dès 2016 il disait les
éoliennes basta bon alors ça serait
tentant un démontrer du doigt en leur
disant bah on a trouvé les deux
coupables enfin c'est c'est peut-être un
petit peu injustif regardez ces deux
cartes vous voyez donc en bleu là à
droite c'est là les endroits où il y a
plus de vent en France donc plus c'est
foncé plus il y a de vent et à gauche
c'est l'implantation des éoliennes donc
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'en fait il y a
des endroits où il y a énormément de
vent comme le couloir du Rhône en bas où
il y a pas tellement d'éoliennes et en
revanche la moitié sont consacrés dans
les hautes sont concentre en allait les
Hauts-de-France il y en a même beaucoup
dans le grand est finalement je n'ai pas
un endroit spécialement pour tout il y a
comme une sorte d'injustice qui tête et
nerve un peu les gens qui habitent dans
ces régions et là le président a dit
aujourd'hui on va la réparer c'est
injustice on écoute
si on veut atteindre notre sobriété et
nos objectifs 2050 on devra faire de
l'éolien sur terre devra le faire il va
falloir là aussi mieux concerter mieux
prévoir faudra aussi ouvrir le jeu parce
qu'on est en fait concentré l'éolien
terrestre sur très peu territoire très
peu donc va falloir ouvrir le jeu ouvrir
le jeu pour le terrestre et sur le
offshore alors l'éolien en mer raté pour
le cocorico pire parce que ce parc
d'éolien marin qu'on vient d'installer
il a été lancé par Nicolas Sarkozy en
2011 et en 2011 on était déjà en retard
c'est à dire que les Danois par exemple
avaient lancé des éoliennes en mer 20
ans auparavant mais bon les français ou
pas rien impossible pour un Français
donc ensuite on va se retrouver elle est
manche et on va faire un joli parc de
laine regarder Nicolas Sarkozy avait un
grand projet 10 milliards et il avait
prévu en 2020 600 éoliennes donc on est
en 2022 et
les 80 premières éoliennes en mer donc
là c'est c'est cocoricoa que là je suis
très très
ce qu'il faut faire alors écoutez le
président a beaucoup réfléchi et je
crois que quitte à vous surprendre il
s'est dit que la meilleure manière pour
attraper notre retard c'était d'aller
plus vite et oui c'est ça mais il faut
le faire encore parce que regardez nous
on a mis 10 ans pour construire ce parc
et on nous explique que les Allemands
les Anglais les Espagnols ils mettent la
moitié du temps 5 ans alors c'est quoi
le problème pas spécialement la
construction ça a pris trois ans non ce
qui est long c'est les 7 ans qui a eu de
démarches contestation respect des
règles administratives et donc c'est ce
délai que le président cherche
raccourcir va y avoir un projet de loi
sur ce sujet pour raccourcir ses délais
de moitié je crois et ça ne vise pas que
l'éolien ça vise tout le renouvelable on
l'écoute trois ans pour un projet
photovoltaïque c'est un bon objectif
pour les petits projets on doit même
faire plus rapide
et donc pour cela il y a une loi qui va
arriver mais aussi une mobilisation de
l'administration j'ai évoqué ce sujet
devant nos préfets il y a quelques jours
à l'Elysée qui est clé et je veux à cet
égard qu'on aille deux fois plus vite au
moins pour les projets renouvelables au
moins deux fois plus vite et c'est
possible et c'est possible donc là on se
dit que c'est bien parti mais il y a des
bas il est pas exclu si vous voulez que
après avoir longtemps reproché au
président de ne pas avancer sur le
dossier de l'éolien maintenant on lui
dise mais enfin vous allez beaucoup trop
vite ça c'est possible donc je vous
laisse en débattre alors on va débattre
du projet de loi dans un instant
évidemment savoir si c'est à la hauteur
ou pas les moyens les délais jusqu'où on
peut gagner du temps mais d'abord je
voudrais qu'on fasse une forme de
comment dire de diagnostic qui est
responsable de notre retard un immense
retard français Stéphane blackowski la
bien expliqué si on regarde la
production
comparée par rapport à nos voisins
européens on va voir ça dans un instant
par rapport au Royaume-Uni par rapport à
l'Allemagne la production d'éolien mais
c'est quasiment
la moitié en France on est sur un
rapport de de un pour deux donc c'est
c'est catastrophique est-ce que c'est
l'état est-ce que c'est la mentalité les
citoyens les contestations la difficulté
pour les riverains est-ce que ce sont
les industriels parce que ça prend du
temps ces chantiers est-ce que ce sont
les élus locaux qui ont les yeux rivés
sur les échéances électorales à qui la
faute qui est responsable Sylvain
Maillard
mais ce bois peut-être pouvoir trouver
un consensus on voit que depuis
probablement une presque une vingtaine
d'années maintenant il y a eu des
louvoiements entre plus ou moins de
nucléaires et le fait d'avoir d'autres
énergies tout en rappelant que le
nucléaire est une énergie peu cher et
évidemment le renouvelable apparaissait
comme une énergie beaucoup plus cher on
a eu aussi
pas dans l'éolien mais dans le panneau
photovoltaïque tous les abus on a connu
ça tous les abus qui ont refroidi le
développement du photovoltaïque en
France bref depuis
2011 on a eu pardon et je voyais
vraiment parler 2011 on a eu évidemment
Fukushima avec un désintérêt par rapport
au nucléaire qui fait que pendant des
années des années au fond le mix n'a pas
eu de choix on n'a pas décidé si on
devait aller plus dans l'éolien si on
devait aller plus dans le photovoltaïque
ou en tout cas on a accompagné une
modification tranquille et on voit qu'on
est très en retard alors on est en
retard aussi bien au niveau de la
production pourrait se dire que sur les
installations ça pourrait être un peu
mieux que les autres alors là c'est
catastrophique aussi quand on regarde 18
GW de puissance installée en 2021 c'est
63 gigawatts en Allemagne comment vous
voyez au fond
les raisons de ce retard qu'est-ce qui
peut l'expliquer s'il fallait ordonner
les responsabilités
d'abord je pense qu'il faut savoir
saluer le fait que il y a un retour dans
un peu de sérénité dans le débat ça
c'est un point qui est important vous le
point de pied tout à l'heure sur la
manière dont notamment la filière a été
éolienne a été traitée pendant les
élections régionales et pendant les
élections présidentielles
moi mon on se demandait pourquoi en fait
et quand on regarde un petit peu avec le
recul il y a des moments on peut pas
s'empêcher de penser que pendant ce
qu'on
organisait de la polémique autour de
éolien et nucléaire on expliquait pas ce
qu'on faisait en matière de transition
énergétique parce qu'il faut quand même
pas oublier que 65% de la consommation
d'énergie que l'on continue à consommer
vient des énergies fossiles et ça c'est
quand même le gros sujet il faut
absolument sortir les énergies fossiles
bon ça c'est un premier point deuxième
point quand on regarde un petit peu ce
qui se passe chez nos voisins il y a
trois sujets qui sont importants si on
veut rattraper notre retard 1 il faut
qu'on améliore notre méthode de travail
cette méthode de travail elle doit
passer par la planification c'est et
vers l'avenir la planification
dans la campagne
de comprendre comment on est arrivé là
justement
sans organiser de planification à
l'échelle des façades maritimes ça c'est
vraiment et donc il faut absolument que
désormais on se mette à planifier en
partie l'injustice sur l'éolien
terrestre on l'a vu sur la carte
deuxième élément ça c'est extrêmement
important on n'a pas mis les moyens dans
les services de l'État ont aujourd'hui
on ne fait pas une politique publique en
matière de transition énergétique et
globalement de transition écologique en
définissant seulement des objectifs et
en oubliant qu'en fait sans compétences
et sans bras on ne met pas ça veut dire
qu'il manque de fonctionnaires pour
comprendre ces politiques publiques les
mettre en oeuvre dans les
administrations on travaille
régulièrement avec les services
déconcentrés de l'État il est services
déconcentrés de l'État avec qui ont des
moments où on tisse des liens qui nous
disent mais monsieur en fait j'y arrive
plus je peux même pas instruire j'ai pas
les moyens de le faire mais ces derniers
points qui est important il faut quand
même la formation
moyen les nombres les nombres des
personnes le nombre de personnes
affectées
consacré à l'énergie et donc
effectivement on a vécu dans un certain
confort en se disant que vous le
ministère Haddock Agnès sur sur
l'énergie Loïc Prud'homme votre regard
les les principaux responsables de ce
retard il y a un vrai défaut de volonté
politique c'était évident quand l'on
voit effectivement comment le potentiel
a été
ignoré je pense par un aveuglement aussi
par notre nucléaire historique qui nous
qui semblait en tout cas pour les
dirigeants politiques nous mettent à
l'abri de tout besoin de transition et
nous quand ça fait plus de 10 ans au
moins on a cette cohérence à la France
insoumise dire il faut engager la
bifurcation et que c'est pas maintenant
qu'on est au pied du mur qu'il faut
l'engager c'est des défauts de volonté
politique et je rejoins monsieur sur sur
la question effectivement des quand on a
une volonté politique des moyens à
engager des politiques et des politiques
publiques quand dans l'exposé politique
c'est qu'en général général il y a des
habitants des électeurs qui ne sont pas
prêts et donc on pourrait parler presque
un problème culturel aussi non c'est
l'arbre qui cache la forêt vraiment
quand on veut un stylet donné des
trajectoires de politique énergétique et
on le voit sur le nucléaire on a demandé
la vie à personne le gouvernement a
décidé dans les années 70 et ça c'est
fait parce qu'on a mis les moyens pour
développer qu'on soit d'accord ou pas et
c'est pas le débat la question si on
avait décidé il y a 10 ans que l'éolien
le photovoltaïque était une priorité on
nous mettrait pas aujourd'hui que le
temps moyen d'instruction pour l'un et
de 5 ans et pour l'autre de 7 ans parce
qu'on aurait mis les moyens
effectivement dans les services publics
pour mener ce qui est absolument
nécessaire et il est pas question de
pour nous en tout cas de simplifier les
procédures ou de faire ça à la va vite
et n'importe comment mais de mettre les
moyens pour que ce soit instruit dans
les délais correctement avec les coudes
des habitants avec le respect des
procédures d'enquête publique etc etc
dans ces conditions là l'acceptabilité
finalement elle vient elle vient
justement pour se figurer les choses on
va se sujet si vous voulez bien dans le
chantier de Saint-Nazaire étape par
étape et je vous donnerai la parole
juste après Franck Louvrier parce que ce
chantier vous le connaissez bien puisque
de là vous êtes à La Baule on aperçoit
ses 80 éoliennes c'est un reportage de
Marco pommier avec Maël Morin au pied de
ses immenses éoliennes en pleine mer le
président Emmanuel Macron est tout
sourire c'est l'aboutissement d'un vaste
chantier vieux de 10 ans les 80 turbines
of Shore fonctionneront 50% du temps
grâce au vendu large et voir ses
éoliennes tournées est aussi une
victoire pour le gouvernement après une
décennie de guérilla juridique des
recours devant les tribunaux des
centaines de réunions avec les habitants
les pêcheurs et des associations
environnementales farouchement opposées
au projet 80 éoliennes se fait déjà
un impact important au niveau du sol
puisque
l'enfonce par battage ont fort sur une
vingtaine de mètres de profondeur 110 km
de câbles vous voyez déjà tout ce que le
ravage que l'on peut faire au fond
depuis le bord de la plage face au parc
off shore le spectacle n'est plus le
même et les avis des habitants restent
mitigés
quand on est arrivé parce que là la fois
d'avant qu'on était là il y avait rien
puis là bon je trouve que si on a
vraiment besoin d'électricité on n'aura
pas trop le choix c'est mieux que de
refaire partir les usines à charbon pour
avoir une énergie plus saine je pense là
normalement nous a dit que les éoliennes
il y en avait des nouvelles générations
donc comme le contrat était signé il y a
10 20 ans on a les anciennes générations
au lieu des toutes derniers cris quoi
donc c'est des non-sens qui sont
constants mais la guerre contre les
éoliennes n'est pas tout à fait terminée
les communes du littoral cherchent à
obtenir davantage de compensation
financières de l'État ici à Batz-sur-Mer
c'est 280 000 euros chaque année un
montant insuffisant pour l'adjoint de
cette commune la plus proche des
éoliennes une commune qui a 1 2 10
éoliennes dans son champ de vision quel
que soit la distance c'est les mêmes
principes que que Batz-sur-Mer qui en a
à 12 qui est la plus proche étant à 12
km et demi la moitié des éoliennes sont
déjà en activité et l'entièreté du parc
fonctionnera dès cet hiver elles
alimenteront un électricité 20% des
habitants du département de
Loire-Atlantique
Frank Louvrier
racontez-nous un petit peu ce que ce que
vous avez vécu ce que vous retenez au
fond des différentes étapes de ce
chantier qui a duré plus plus de 10 ans
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on a franchi un
cap les mentalités ont changé ou est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui encore ça reste compliqué
sur le terrain d'abord je vais répondre
à votre première question c'est qui est
responsable c'est la politique
politicienne qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
ici pour parler d'un cas concret parce
que comme on est le premier parquet
éolien français à être inauguré par le
Président de la République aujourd'hui
il faut comprendre pourquoi on en est
arrivé là c'est très simple dans les
années 70 il y a eu un plan un plan
nucléaire qui permettait notamment de
mettre des centrales nucléaires un peu
partout en France et chaque métropole
française avait en fin de compte sa
centrale nucléaire ici il y a une
résistance qui a amené à l'abandon du
projet par le Président de la République
à l'époque François Mitterrand en 1981
et là nous sommes retrouvés plusieurs
années après en sous-capacité
énergétique parce que nous n'avions pas
bien évidemment la possibilité de
produire de l'énergie comme on peut le
faire d'autres métropoles avec leur
centrale nucléaire et c'est comme ça que
est arrivé dans les années je dirais d'y
a à peu près maintenant 15 ans c'est à
dire 2007-2008 sous l'impulsion de
Nicolas Sarkozy et à l'époque du
Grenelle de l'environnement
dirigé par Jean-Louis Borloo le projet
de parc éolien en mer ici à La Baule
pour permettre de compenser cette
absence et cette facture à régler en fin
de compte de du fait que nous n'avons
pas de capacité énergétiques suffisantes
voilà comme on en est arrivé là donc en
fin de compte c'est les lâcheté
politicienne notamment de la gauche à
l'époque qui est en fin de compte a
abandonner les projets de central et
nous a mis dans des situations de sous
capacité énergétiques alors maintenant
aujourd'hui il faut penser à demain bien
évidemment qu'il faut continuer à faire
des centrales nucléaires parce que c'est
une nécessité mais il faut développer le
énergétique avec des parc éoliens en mer
il est normal que il faut comprendre la
réticence des habitants vous imaginez
que du jour au lendemain que vous avez
vécu et entendu
puisque vous n'êtes pas très très loin
de ce chantier qu'est-ce qui a été très
difficile à accepter autrement vous
ouvrez vos fenêtres cet été et il y a 80
éoliennes qui ont apparu au large
c'était la côte sauvage c'est devenu une
côte industrielle et donc la réaction de
la population elle est à comprendre et
il est normal parce qu'en plus le
travail de pédagogie avant n'a pas été
fait à juste titre par les élus par le
gouvernement etc donc on s'est retrouvé
dans une situation où à la fois c'est un
mal nécessaire un mâle parce que bien
évidemment ça dévisage notre paysage
mais nécessaire parce que nous sommes en
sous capacité énergétique il va falloir
produire de l'énergie et heureusement
qu'on a des parcs éolien en mer pour le
faire sinon cet hiver va être difficile
déjà on fait redémarrer la centrale à
charbon de Cordemais ici à proximité
pour permettre de compenser cette
capacité énergétique en attendant bien
évidemment le démarrage de ce parc
éolien en mer
que vous décrivez très bien il est au
fond bien vécu en tout cas accepter
davantage parce qu'on
sent bien tournant avec ce qui s'est
passé cette été la sécheresse les
incendies avec l'urgence climatique la
guerre en Ukraine est-ce que les
mentalités sont clairement on le sent
sur le terrain en train de changer vous
avez raison le contexte international
ne fait qu'amplifier la nécessité
d'avoir un mix énergétique c'est-à-dire
de production
d'électricité par l'éolien mais aussi
par le solaire mais aussi bien
évidemment dans le domaine agricole avec
la méthanisation etc etc mais il faut
bien évidemment que ça chemine et vous
comprenez bien que le choc qui a eu lieu
il y a quelques mois maintenant fait que
il a fallu beaucoup de pédagogie et nous
les maires c'est la raison pour laquelle
ce que j'ai expliqué au président de la
République cet après-midi qui nous a
accordé un long entretien avec les mers
pour qu'on lui explique la situation
pour qu'il comprenne que bien sûr que
c'est une réussite industrielle
indéniable le parc éolien en mer bien
sûr que ça nous projette dans les dans
les années à venir en nous sécurisant de
la production mais il faut comprendre
aussi que de l'autre côté vu de la côte
c'est un paysage qui a été en partie
défiguré et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a demandé notamment que la
compensation financière prenne en compte
bien sûr les communes les plus touchées
alors on va se tourner vers l'avenir
bonsoir faut que vilaine Guyenne et
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
spécialisé politique publique sur
l'énergie et notamment européenne pour
l'institut Jacques Delors qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont fait nos voisins au
Royaume-Uni Allemagne qui pourrait nous
servir d'exemple on a compris qu'ils ont
pris le tournant quoi il y a 20 ans
pas nous on a maintenant le diagnostic
sur sur les raisons les responsables les
politiques manifestement sont en
première place mais mais qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait prendre comme
exemple sur eux si on mettait un coup
d'accélérateur aujourd'hui ils ont mis
en place des signaux politiques très
forts pour pouvoir décarboner leur
électricité parce qu'en France vous
l'avez rappelé on sait longtemps reposer
sur une électricité décarbonée notamment
grâce au nucléaire ils ont mis en place
des mesures incitatives c'est à dire
soutenir les industriel
qui sont les acteurs pour que on arrive
à se figurer les choses parce que on
entend un an deux ans trois ans maximum
chez nos voisins 10 voir 20 ans en
France qu'est-ce qui se passe en fait
c'est assez simple dans le domaine de
l'éolien en mer c'est l'État qui assure
la maîtrise ouvrage donc c'est à dire
que c'est l'État qui va d'abord lancer
les études qui vont permettre
d'identifier
les qualités des fonds marins les
questions environnementales et sur la
base des résultats de ces études il va
définir ce qu'on appelle une macrosone
c'est-à-dire une grande zone autour de
laquelle il va organiser un débat public
qui va mettre l'ensemble des co-usagers
de la mer puisque la politique française
c'est dans les parcs vous pouvez avoir
de l'activité notamment d'activité de
pêche donc on réunit les pêcheurs le
transport maritime les élus locaux les
citoyens leur dit ben voilà on a ce
terrain de jeu là les données sont à peu
près stabilisées
la présence de la Commission nationale
du débat public dit nous c'est un an
grand maximum moi c'est un an pourquoi
c'est pas nous les fauteurs
ensuite sur cette base là du coup on
définit avec un peu plus de précision la
zone qui est proposée pour
l'implantation et on lance l'état lance
les appels d'offres pour que les
industriels
des postent leur propositions
etc total ou d'autres jeux
souhaitent installer le parc à tel coup
dans telle condition avec tel type de
technologie et à tel prix et donc là il
y a un jury qui se rassemblent qui
sélectionne le parc OK et à partir du
moment où l'État donne sa décision sur
la proposition du riz là on rentre dans
l'étape suivante qui est l'étape la plus
délicate qui l'étape des recours où là
du coup on peut prendre un peu plus de
temps un an et demi deux ans et à partir
du moment on a purgé les recours du coup
là on peut lancer les travaux et les
travaux durent mais là dans le parc de
Saint-Nazaire ça a duré 3 ans
alors Loïc prudent on a un projet de loi
dont on connaît les grandes lignes parce
que justement ils viennent à accélérer
en raccourcissant les délais des
procédures avec un système de dérogation
on va voir les principales mesures de ce
texte la fin des consultations pour les
tout petits chantiers et aux liens
simplifier les procédures en étant dans
les votes publiques par voie
électronique mutualiser ça c'est la
grande mesure les débats publics
citoyens dont vous parliez par façade
maritime pour l'éolien en mer donc tout
l'Atlantique par exemple ça va dans le
bon sens ça c'est on se dit c'est ce
qu'il fallait faire pour pour gagner un
peu de temps non mais je pense que on
l'a déjà dit tout à l'heure la question
des des politiques publiques et
notamment des instructions c'est
effectivement l'absence de volonté et de
moyens mis et on voit que quand Chantal
Jouanno dit chez nous c'est un an et que
finalement si derrière ça ça roulait un
petit peu de manière un peu efficace on
y arriverait moi ce que je voulais dire
c'est revenir par rapport à les propos
de Monsieur qui expert et qui nous dit
voilà c'est le soutien aussi financier
de l'État qui a fait des défauts parce
que pourrait rappeler quand même que
stratégiquement notre notre
énergie nucléaire a été développée par
l'État par les moyens de l'État et
aujourd'hui on se dit 20 ans après mais
pourquoi l'éolien n'a pas progresser les
photosvoltaïques n'a pas progressé parce
qu'on est arrivé à un moment une période
où on a dit mais finalement c'est le
marché qui va décider du développement
de tel ou telle énergie en fonction de
sa rentabilité ou pas et aujourd'hui
comme on avait soi-disant un nucléaire
peu cher parce qu'on n'avait pas les
coûts complets voilà aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit
on n'aura jamais dû sortir de ça
on a on a on a remis ce développement à
des logiques de marché qui sont pas des
logiques en fait d'anticipation de long
terme mais de rentabilité de court terme
et aujourd'hui on se trouve avec des
cours de l'énergie parce que le marché
devient fou il était déjà avant mais là
c'est un paroxysme et on dit bah voilà
maintenant effectivement ça vaut ramener
un projet de loi on est à l'Assemblée
nationale vous êtes député on va on va
en connaître les détails la semaine
prochaine il est pas présenté encore
mais on comprend bien sa philosophie
vous y êtes favorable à la France
insoumise vous voterez ce nous tout ce
qui permet de favoriser les énergies
renouvelables et leur déploiement bien
sûr mais avec du soutien financier pas
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure pas en
faisant des procédures à
rabais des procédures environnementales
mais en donnant des moyens publics à
instruire correctement les dossiers et
puis surtout pas en nous mettant dans
l'exposé des motifs de ce projet de loi
que la trajectoire est de construire 6
EPR et que finalement c'est ce qui fait
l'alpha et l'oméga de notre politique
énergétique
des délais au nucléaire c'est qu'on nous
demande pardon de vous interrompre on
nous demande c'est d'avoir un consensus
populaire et y compris à l'Assemblée
nationale et on vient avec un projet où
finalement la discussion a déjà eu lieu
avant qu'on ait été interrogés
il y a la question des délais vous
pensez vraiment que ça peut changer la
donne et puis il y a la question des
moyens on sait déjà que le Président de
la République c'était avant avant
l'élection s'est engagée sur un plan
énergie construire 50 par éoliens d'ici
2050 40 gigawatts de puissance on repart
dans des grands objectifs comme ça
affichés c'est tenable c'est 50 c'est on
sort de d'une campagne électorale ou le
président de la République a affiché
très clairement le projet évidemment
construire des nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires évidemment construire 50
parcs éolien
offshore de cette même dimension partout
en France ici 2050 et puis multiplié par
10 le photovoltaïque très clairement les
données sont sur par contre il nous faut
accélérer dans les procédures vous
l'avez dit ça prend et vous avez pris
cet exemple 10 ans moi vous savez la
première mon premier déplace en avec
Sébastien Lecornu à ce moment-là début
2017 je viens d'être élu je suis allé à
Saint-Nazaire inaugurer la première
éolienne qu'on vient de mettre en mer ça
fait 6 ans
six ans alors cléolienne était déjà
construite avant qu'elle soit reliée
installée reliée c'est aussi un problème
français où il nous faut accélérer les
procédures pour le rendre plus dynamique
pour qu'on décarbonne plus vite
notre nos énergies et puis surtout on a
besoin de plus d'électricité que ce que
nous avions besoin auparavant et nous en
aurons besoin de plus en plus donc il
nous faut absolument accompagner ça et
je vais prendre juste je vais terminer
là-dessus vous savez par exemple les
Jeux Olympiques nous ont voté une loi
pour accélérer
les l'installation des différentes
installations pardon des Jeux Olympiques
avec une loi qui nous permettait
justement d'accélérer c'est un peu la
même idée c'est de dire évidemment il
faut l'ensemble des des discussions avec
les parties prenantes mais il faut pas
multiplication de recours parce que ce
dont on n'a pas parlé depuis tout à
l'heure c'est les contentieux les
contentieux qui sont justifiés et
parfois injustifié alors justement c'est
toute la difficulté entre une démocratie
et l'urgence climatique
combinais tant longtemps court Franck
Louvrier vous qui êtes mère les
républicains de La Baule vous serez un
partenaire du gouvernement pour
accompagner cette loi si si elle est
adoptée ça va être compliqué dans
l'hémicycle c'est sûr sur les énergies
renouvelables mais faire passer auprès
de la population que il y aura peut-être
moins de temps pour faire ses recours
moins de temps pour faire des études
d'impact écologique moins de temps aussi
pour pour consulter les citoyens en tout
cas l'esprit du projet loi me séduit
parce qu'en fin de compte l'esprit du
projet de loi c'est sans doute moins
d'excès de contentieux et plus de
dialogue et c'est exactement l'objectif
qu'il faut se donner parce que faut pas
confondre les excès juridiques auxquels
nous sommes confrontés quotidiennement
par le fait notamment dans le secteur de
l'urbanisme on dépose des des
autorisations d'agrandissement ou des
permis de construire on est bloqué par
un excès et un juridisme incroyable et
puis le fait de la nécessité de
l'impérius nécessité du dialogue et de
la pédagogie ce qui a manqué sur ce
premier parc éolien et qui facera sans
doute et je l'ai rappelé au président de
la République cet après-midi qu'il faut
sans doute encore se consacrer beaucoup
plus nous les élus à l'explication des
projets vous savez quand on explique que
on n'a pas de centrale nucléaire qu'on a
en sous capacité énergétique qui font un
parc éolien les gens comprennent la
seule chose qui qu'on leur explique pas
c'est sûr que c'est compliqué de l'avoir
toute la chronologie des faits et je
pense que à chaque fois qu'on a ce type
de projet il faut justement amplifier
dialogue et par contre réduire les excès
et le juridique parce que c'est là
dessus qu'on perd du temps faut qu'elles
viennent pour continuer sur la
comparaison
c'est nous qui sommes dans l'excès de
contentieux en France on a cette culture
là de la contestation devant les
tribunaux et donc on traîne en longueur
ces dossiers ou c'est pareil ailleurs le
consensus il existe partout puisque les
références sont toujours concernés par
ces questions là mais ce dont on se rend
compte c'est qu'il y a souvent aussi un
effet d'entraînement une fois que vous
j'ai commencé à poser les bases du
développement de l'éolien maritime ou
alors du développement d'éolien
terrestre on se rend compte que les
populations comprennent l'utilité de
cela et du fait du contexte géopolitique
actuel il faut rappeler le rôle de
l'éolien l'éolien ça permet d'éviter des
émissions de tonnes de CO2 en 2019
c'était 5 millions de tonnes de CO2 qui
ont été invités en France pour éviter de
brûler du gaz et ça va permettre au
cours de cet hiver de produire de
l'électricité et ça marche l'éolien
parce que peut-être pour ceux qui nous
regardent beaucoup de gens se disent oui
mais l'éolien voilà c'est conditionné au
vent et le vent ça se décrète pas le
vent ça ne se décrète pas mais au cours
de l'hiver les éoliennes permettent de
produire de l'électricité autour de 7 à
8% et lorsqu'on sait qu'on a un parc
nucléaire qui est un peu en difficulté
en ce moment ça va être très utile c'est
pour ça qu'il va falloir aussi accélérer
et un dernier point ce qu'on est en
train de faire sur l'éolien maritime il
va aussi falloir le faire sur l'éolien
terrestre pourquoi parce qu'en réalité
on se rend bien compte de l'utilité des
énergies renouvelables pour se passer
dès à présent du gaz russe qui ne sera
plus là vraisemblablement au cours des
prochains mois à venir oui c'est une
évidence et la même chose sur le
photovoltaïque par ailleurs
il faut il faut aussi
aller plus plus rapidement moi je
voudrais juste rappeler une chose et je
suis pour le pour le coup d'accord avec
Sylvain Maillard sur la question des des
rapidités de raccordement j'ai eu cette
question aussi avec des producteurs moi
localement sur ma circonscription
d'énergie renouvelable qui nous disent
les questions de raccordement par
l'opérateur qui est chargé justement du
réseau sont très très longues alors
voilà il faut aussi qu'on regarde et
j'espère qu'on aura ce débat
gérer le réseau alors vous donnez 10
mais parce que je pense que c'est pareil
comment on est dans une culture de de
ces grandes couleurs peut-être sur une
note un peu positive on voit bien qu'on
est un tournant que les mentalités
changent de toute façon tout le monde
comprend bien qu'on pourra pas faire que
du nucléaire qu'il faudra faire aussi du
renouvelable tous les scénarios de
l'archéologie le disent il y a de
l'emploi à la clé des professionnels les
industriels sont prêts pour le coup on
est totalement prêt il faut qu'on ait
des signaux qui soient qui soit très
clairs d'où la nécessité de planifier et
en termes d'emploi les chiffres sont
nets éolien en mer aujourd'hui c'est
6000 emplois en France et l'éolien
terrestre c'est 18000 emplois en France
qui fait de nous la première filière
d'emploi d'énergie renouvelables
électriques devant l'hydraulique devant
le photovoltaïque etc donc
les ambitions afficher de voilà de
monter en force sur l'éolien notamment
offshore merci beaucoup on va suivre ce
débat dans l'hémicycle quand le texte
arrivera il promet quelques voilà un
poignet de droite-gauche quelque chose
me dit que ça va pas être si simple
merci merci beaucoup merci à vous on va
à présent accueillir notre grand témoin
il a vu le Parti socialiste
s'autodétruire sous ses yeux quand il
travaillait à l'Elysée il était aux
premières loges quand François Hollande
a décidé de ne pas se représenter depuis
il est resté de gauche malgré pas mal
d'états d'âmes il raconte tout ça dans
un livre personnel mais pas désespéré
Gaspard gantzen rejoint tout de suite
après l'invitation de Stéphanie des
pierres
si on vous invite Gaspard ganzer c'est
parce que vous êtes un observateur
averti du paysage politique à gauche
vous dirigez votre propre agence de
communication et surtout vous avez été
le conseiller de François Hollande à
l'Élysée durant 3 ans une expérience que
vous avez racontée dans un premier livre
aujourd'hui vous publiez un nouvel opus
êtes-vous encore de gauche enfin plutôt
suis-je encore de gauche né dans une
famille de droite et nark la même année
qu'Emmanuel Macron vous rejoignez le PS
en 2002 après l'un des pires moments de
son histoire quand Lionel Jospin est
éliminé dès le premier tour de la
présidentielle après une éphémère
candidature indépendante aux municipales
dans la capitale en 2020 vous vous
rallier à celle des marcheurs en 2022
vous observez avec étonnement la
campagne dan Hidalgo qui maintient coûte
que coûte sa candidature à la
présidentielle je défendrai notre projet
et les Françaises et c'est trancheront
et il tranche dans le vif 1,7% des voix
une défaite record pour le PS qui vous
inspire ce commentaire saluons son
courage on peut tout de même
s'interroger sur sa lucidité vous êtes
bien plus sévère avec Benoît Hamon la
parachutique caricatural ou Olivier fort
à qui vous reprochez comme au PS tout
entier leur obsession d'inventaire du
quinquennat Hollande vous n'avez pas de
mots assez dur envers ce parti
socialiste qui depuis 2017 selon vous
n'a pas su se réinventer une alternance
au niveau national il faut 5 ans ou au
moins trois ans quoi c'est un long
chemin personnel pour la candidate ou le
candidat mais aussi pour l'ensemble du
parti qui doit produire des idées et le
problème du Parti Social codéiné c'est
qu'il a pas suffisamment travaillé sur
le fond d'un point de vue idéologique il
a remporté des élections au niveau local
maintenu du pouvoir local qui était déjà
acquis à sa cause et il s'est pris des
roustes aux européennes et aller aux
élections présidentielles et donc faut
cette ça se reproduise donc c'est le
chemin commence maintenant pour qu'en
2027 il n'y a pas les mêmes difficultés
malgré tout vous conc
luez encore
devant leader sans moyens sans idée
nouvelle cette gauche là a-t-elle un
avenir
bonsoir Gaspard Gander et merci d'être
là vous avez répondre à cette question
qui vous êtes intéressé par Stéphanie
dans un instant mais c'est drôle parce
que quand on vous lit vous dites oui oui
je suis resté de gauche mais il vous
faut quand même un livre entier pour
vous en rendre compte c'était pas si
évident que ça quand même après tout ce
parcours oui c'est vrai parce que j'ai
appris la 2017 et la non candidature de
François Hollande j'ai certainement été
traversé par le doute d'autant plus
qu'il y avait la victoire d'Emmanuel
Macron qui appelait au dépassement du
clivage droite-gauche et je pense que
j'ai été séduit comme beaucoup par l'air
du temps en me disant pourquoi pas
finalement peut-être qu'il y a une
troisième boîte qui est possible
le contexte on vous donnait candidat au
législatives et puis finalement c'était
en Bretagne je crois ça ne fait pas fait
vous êtes parti au municipales en 2020
sur une liste citoyenne et puis
finalement au dernier moment vous avez
décidé de retirer votre candidature et
vous choisissez de vous rallier à Agnès
Buzyn la candidate macroniste de
l'époque il faut le reconnaître vous
racontez très bien que vous connaissez
Emmanuel Macron vous l'avez rencontré
sur les bancs de Léna et vous continuez
à dialoguer avec lui régulièrement vous
n'êtes pas macroniste franchement non je
peux être avoir des relations
personnelles amicales avec le prendre de
la République rassurez-vous je prends
pas une bière avec lui tous les jours
tout en étant critique de la politique
qui l'a conduite en tant que prend la
République je souhaite le meilleur parce
que le meilleur à notre pays en revanche
les orientations politiques qu'il a
choisi pour son quinquennat dès le
premier encore plus dans le deuxième se
tourne de plus en plus vers la droite et
vers des valeurs et une politique qui
n'est pas la mienne donc il n'est pas de
gauche pour vous puisque c'est la
question du livre en tout cas du coup
encore de gauche Emmanuel Macron est de
droite je pense qu'il est devenu un
homme de droite je pense qu'il a été de
gauche certainement mais que dans
l'exercice du pouvoir dans certainement
pour des raisons idéologiques pour des
raisons tactiques il est devenu un homme
de droite certainement parce que le pays
est à droite et que c'est avec son
électorat était à droite donc il a le
droit d'évoluer personnellement mais là
en l'occurrence c'est sombre alors
peut-être que je me suis aussi rendu de
compte que j'étais de gauche grâce à
Emmanuel Macron parce que je me suis
rendu compte que je n'étais pas d'accord
avec lui alors vous êtes de gauche
social-démocrate réformiste quand on
regarde ce qu'ils le sont encore et qui
s'affirment comme tel c'est pas on va
dire
la jeunesse il y a Bernard Cazeneuve par
exemple qui tente de lancer un mouvement
politique ou de réflexion c'est ça peut
être lui la relève cet avenir vous le
voyez un carnet par qui c'est une des
questions que je me pose à la fin du
livre et il y a pas de réponse évidente
François Mitterrand disait souvent à
chaque fois qu'il Francis une décennie
la vie commence à 50 ans la vie commence
aux 60 la vie commence à 70 donc
pourquoi pas Bernard Cazeneuve il a pas
encore 70 ans et même loin de là il est
encore jeune mais il y en a d'autres qui
peuvent contribuer bien plus jeunes plus
vieux des femmes des hommes dans le
groupe parlementaire socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a des gens
remarquables gens de guerre
mais je pense que certains après j'ai
pas sondé leur âme ni leur cœur mais on
fait le choix de la news peut-être pour
des raisons de tactique électorales mais
aussi parce que peut-être le peuple de
gauche appelait ça de ses vœux mais il
en pense pas moins et peut-être qu'ils
attendent aussi leur heure parce que ils
attendent de voir comment tout cela va
durer je crois que ça durera pas ne
durera pas on suit même persuadé
d'ailleurs les événements récents que
l'on viendra certainement montre que
tout ça est quand même très fragile avec
un peu de recul qui l'a tué cette gauche
là je pense que plusieurs personnes se
sont mis ensemble pour y arriver je
pense que François Hollande son
entourage dont moi on est une part de
responsabilité si nous avions
parfaitement réussi dans l'exercice du
pouvoir on en serait pas là mais on n'a
pas échoué tout seul on vous pouvez
aussi avec le groupe parlementaire qui
s'est divisé avec le gouvernement qui a
pas pu s'empêcher de s'agiter à des
ambitions personnelles et puis peut-être
que on n'a pas de suite tous ensemble
accepter l'exercice du pouvoir les
compromis que nécessitent cet exercice
du pouvoir et on a peut-être pêché à
certains instants et moments pardon par
des manques de clarification politique
et de logique c'est aussi un livre
d'autocritique d'une certaine façon
beaucoup
Anne Hidalgo aussi vous pouvez nous
expliquer parce que là franchement c'est
s'il y a même pas de mots ce qui est
bizarre c'est que évidemment un échec
une des routes la sienne essentiellement
la sienne je pense d'une part de
responsabilité à l'évidence elle s'était
pas assez préparée pour sa sélection
elle a donné le sentiment parfois
d'improviser une candidature son
véritable cheminement personnel ni
idéologique ni programmatique mais
certainement que le PS aussi ne l'a pas
assez soutenu on n'a pas senti un
collectif très uni derrière elle que ça
soit les dirigeants actu du Parti
socialiste ou les anciens donc résultat
les gens sont allés regarder ailleurs
chez Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a
certainement récupéré des électeurs
socialistes au premier dès le premier
tour et chez Emmanuel Macron donc les
électeurs socialistes ils étaient
partout sauf chez Anne Hidalgo ils
étaient plus chez Macron et chez
Mélenchon chez Annie d'algo si vous
deviez dire au fond allez on va créer
une force une force réformiste sociale
démocrate quand vous voyez aujourd'hui
il y a trois forces assez clair elle
représente vraiment des espaces
politiques extrêmement distincts Macron
c'est l'Europe le libéralisme
l'entreprise
Mélenchon c'est plus la radicalité on
peut dire l'écologie également avec avec
cette idée quand même d'une place de
l'État extrêmement importante Marine Le
Pen elle veut parler aux classes
populaires l'Europe c'est moins c'est
moins ça c'est beaucoup moins clair mais
n'empêche que on voit très bien les
lignes de fracture est-ce que cet espace
politique là c'est pas celui des 15 20
prochaines années je pense au contraire
je peux me tromper bien évidemment
l'espace politique c'est polarisé de
cette manière là avec ces trois pôles un
pôle national un pôle d'extrême gauche
et un pôle central sans triste mais
Emmanuel Macron sera pas conduit à sa
réélection Jean-Luc Mélenchon a laissé
entendre qu'il a arrêté la vie politique
on est tenté de le croire et quand ta
Marine Le Pen on sent qu'elle en a quand
même un peu marre même si elle est très
présente dans l'hémicycle qui ne vivent
c'est parti que par leurs incarnations
après après le départ d'Emmanuel Macron
et il y a une partie des macronistes de
gauche qui vont chercher ailleurs
peut-être vers les parties socialistes
et il est plus nombreux qui sont à
droite ils vont se battre pour savoir si
ça sera d'armanin le maire Philippe ou
je ne sais qui qui prendra le relais
quand à Marine Le Pen va y avoir
certainement une bataille en son propre
sein et donc ça ouvre des nouvelles
possibilités pour la gauche réformisme
mais aussi pour la gloire réformisme je
suis persuadé que le clivage roi de
gauche va revenir non pas exactement
comme il était avant je crois pas vivre
simplement une parenthèse macroniste et
puis après tout va revenir comme avant
je crois pas du tout en revanche il y a
des grands clivages qui composent la
société vont reprendre le dessus alors
je voudrais maintenant m'adresser aux
communicants que vous êtes parce que
vous avez pris du chant vous n'êtes plus
dans la politique vous dirigez une
société de de conseils en communication
après avoir été le conseiller de la
communication de François Hollande deux
images on va voir Jean-Luc Mélenchon en
meeting immersif et olfactif pendant la
campagne on se souvient la voilà cette
image très impressionnante à un moment
donné il est sur scène et c'est l'océan
qui s'afficher on va voir sans doute
cette image qu'on découvre et puis je
voudrais que on enchaîne avec voilà ça
c'est la planète et puis ensuite il y a
l'océan je voudrais vous montrer voilà
ça c'est très impressionnant
vous montrer également un petit extrait
d'Emmanuel Macron pendant la campagne et
ses petits films ça s'appelait le
candidat on y a vu la pâte Netflix
entièrement produit par par l'Elysée
bien évidemment avec enfin par le
candidat avec un savoir-faire
particulier et puis et puis tout autre
image Marine Le Pen alors elle
au milieu des Français claquants des
bises et multipliant les selfies qui a
tout compris à la communication de ces
trois-là je pense que du point de vue
strict de la communication c'est
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a fait la
meilleure campagne parce qu'il partait
quand même de très loin mais il pouvait
s'appuyer sur quand même un savoir-faire
éprouver lors des campagnes potentiel
précédent notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur son rapport à aux
militants et au fond et il est aussi
montré qu'il était très bon dans les
meetings quoi donc il a pensé qu'il a
fait cette remontada incroyable droite
et reconnaissons que Marine Le Pen n'a
pas été maladroite elle a changé son
image elle est apparue comme la plus
sympathique à la fin il y avait un
sondage dans lequel les Français
disaient qu'ils avaient s'il devait
choisir avec qui boire une bière le soir
ça serait avec Marine Le Pen plutôt
qu'avec les autres et enfin Emmanuel
Macron il a pas fait campagne mais il a
gagné donc chapeau l'artiste et à vous
raconter que vous avez essayé de pousser
François Hollande dans votre livre à
faire plus court à arrêter de réécrire
sans cesse des nuisent entières c'est
discours
autant autant long dernière petit
commentaire en tant que communicant
l'affaire catenens comme vous l'avez
trouvé géré par la France insoumise
après notamment le truc de soutien de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon le premier tweet ils
ont été visiblement débordés pris de
vitesse ils ont réagi de façon émotive
et assez peu politique ce qui est
surprenant parce que habituellement ils
sont très bons politiques comme les
insoumis on peut être d'accord ou pas
avec eux ils sont quand même très
habiles là on a vu qu'il réagissait
d'abord pour défendre un camarade
quelqu'un qui était un délai qu'ils ont
pas voulu enfoncer alors qu'il
reconnaissait des faits quand même
extrêmement graves à voir giflé sa femme
ça comprenne donc ils ont pas été bon
mais c'est certainement parce qu'ils ont
laissé parler l'émotion plus que la
raison et se retirer ou se mettre en
retrait d'un mandat de parlementaire
sans démissionner de ce mandala est-ce
que ça peut être compris des Français je
pense que c'est l'histoire de l'infini
en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
Adrien katnens maintenant qui
s'exprimait souvent dans les médias est
plutôt de bonne manière d'avoir du mal à
le faire
dans les coulisses de la chute du Parti
socialiste êtes-vous encore de gauche
c'est personnel il y a des propositions
c'est pas désespéré et c'est aux
éditions Flammarion vous restez avec moi
parce que c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris ce soir
Isabelle lacer revient sur le choc
profond au sein de la société rousse
russe après l'appel à la mobilisation
militaire de Vladimir Poutine on va
parler du passage en force ou pas sur
les retraites avec eldam Honda qui va
nous en dire plus sur le feuilleton de
des retraites donc et puis un nouveau
visage qu'on est ravis d'accueillir le
professeur d'histoire et essayiste Yanis
roder avec ces histoires d'écoles chaque
semaine dans cette émission nos
affranchis les voici bonsoir à vous deux
ravi de vous accueillir Yanis roder ravi
de vous retrouver Isabelle Lasserre on
commence avec vous grand reporters au
Figaro on le sait spécialiste de la
Russie vous aviez été correspondante des
années à Moscou et vous nous dites ce
soir que le régime de Poutine a l'air
sérieusement tanguer en tout cas ce qui
est certain c'est que la mobilisation
même si elle est parti à produire un
effet que le Kremlin n'avait sans doute
pas anticipé c'est à dire une ruée en
quelques heures de des Russes
susceptibles d'être mobilisés sur les
billets d'avion à destination de la
Turquie de l'Arménie et de la Georgie
alors le Kremlin a tenté d'enrayer cet
exode en interdisante aux agences devant
des billets d'avion aux hommes âgés de
25 à 65 ans mais ils peuvent toujours
essayer de quitter la Russie par la
route on a vu des embouteillages
absolument
démentiels à la frontière avec la
Géorgie et avec la Finlande alors est-ce
qu'on est en train d'assister
normalement
c'est la fuite
le grand exode alors est-ce qu'on est-ce
qu'on peut dire qu'on assiste à une
sorte de Maeda en russe ou pas
on en est pas encore là
la plupart il y a eu des manifestations
hier à ékaterimbourg à Moscou dans 38
villes et à peu près 1300
manifestants ont été arrêtés on sait que
depuis l'arrivée de Vladimir Poutine au
pouvoir la plupart de toutes les
révoltes en fait ont été éteinte par la
répression les leaders qu'il s'agissent
de Alexa Navalny ou de Mireille Rhod
ofkowski ont été jetés en prison les
dissidents comme la journaliste Anna
polico scaia ont parfois été assassinés
et depuis plusieurs semaines on voit des
des drôles d'accidents des hommes
d'affaires qui tombent bizarrement de
leurs fenêtre le dernier est tombé d'une
lucarne d'un paquebot en pleine en
pleine haute mer c'était le patron de
Lukoil le plus grand producteur de
pétrole russe alors les Russes
aujourd'hui aussi
ils manifeste parce qu'ils sont
concernés directement par cette
mobilisation mais depuis le début de la
réalisation quand même fait la politique
de l'autruche on ne nous a pas vu avoir
beaucoup de compassion vis-à-vis de la
guerre en Ukraine ils ont plutôt
manifesté une certaine indifférence et
aujourd'hui on a vu qu'il y avait pu une
seule manifestation dans les rues des
grandes villes en Russie il faut
attendre donc imaginez la chute de
Vladimir Poutine en théorie Vladimir
Poutine et le reste le maître absolu en
Russie n'a pas ses comptes à rendre au
polyburant que le que tous les
dirigeants soviétiques avaient à
l'époque de l'URSS mais en même temps on
ne peut plus exclure complètement ce
scénario alors on a vu que ça craquait à
l'intérieur ça tiraille aussi à
l'extérieur la Chine n'a pas encore
lâché Vladimir Poutine enfin lui a quand
même donné un avertissement en disant
reste un petit peu dans les lignes ne
franchis pas la ligne rouge l'Inde a
fait pareil la Turquie a l'air de de
retourner sa veste quand à tous les pays
des îles centrales ils de s'extraire de
l'influence russe l'Europe qui reste
divisée
accentue la pression et tient bon face à
Vladimir Poutine et surtout les
Ukrainiens continuent à enregistrer des
succès incroyables sur le terrain alors
on sait pas très bien l'état de l'armée
russe encore aujourd'hui mais on sait
deux choses il est évident que la
mobilisation partielle déclarée par
Vladimir Poutine n'a pas l'air de faire
beaucoup d'enthousiasme en Russie et en
Ukraine cette armée russe cède assez
facilement sous les coups de boutoir de
l'armée ukrainienne et surtout la
volonté des combattants Ukrainiens or on
sait que si Vladimir Poutine perd sa
guerre il aura quand même des chances de
perdre son fauteuil au Kremlin je suis
ça de près avec vous merci beaucoup
Isabelle la politique à présent avec
Elsa ont un Gava qui n'est pas un
plateau ce soir mais en duplex de Guidel
dans le Morbihan Elsa vous êtes au
rendez-vous de rentrée de du MoDem le
parti de François Bayrou on le sait qui
a aussi ces derniers jours sur les
retraites François Bayrou qui s'est
d'ailleurs trouvé une alliée de poids en
la personne de Yaël Braun pivel la
présidente de l'Assemblée qui elle aussi
n'est pas favorable à l'introduction
d'un amendement dans le budget de la
Sécurité sociale pour passer en force
sur les retraites on va d'abord
l'écouter elle était ce matin sur France
Info puis je vous donne la parole juste
après moi je n'ai jamais été favorable
et c'est une constante chez moi aux
amendements qui portent en eux-mêmes une
réforme d'importance vous l'avez dit
Emmanuel Macron cet argument là parce
que c'est lui qui a mis cette hypothèse
il y a quelques jours vous savez moi
c'est une constante je dis toujours ce
que je pense et je suis assez cohérente
et constante voilà ça le mérite d'être
assez cash Elsa j'imagine que cette
petite phrase n'est pas passée inaperçue
là où vous êtes dans les dans les les
rancentrices on s'en félicite
exactement vous pouvez vous en douter
Myriam on a accueilli bien très
favorablement la prise de position de la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale bah
tout en rappelant que c'est ni plus ni
moins que la position du MoDem ça évolue
le vent tourne son persuadés les élus en
tristes avec qui j'ai discuté pour eux
ils ont l'impression et bien que
l'exécutif finira par écarter cette
hypothèse d'un amendement au budget de
la Sécurité sociale pour faire la
réforme des retraites François Bayrou le
président du MoDem est resté sur cette
ligne écoutez-le il est au micro de
Steven Martin je connais le président de
la République je sais qu'il écoute je
sais qu'il observe
les sentiments du pays je sais
combien
la préparation des réformes est
nécessaire pour que les réformes
aboutissent il a dit ça pendant toute sa
campagne électorale et donc je n'ai
jamais cru
qu'on pourrait imposer une démarche de
de passage en force ou à l'improviste
jamais cru voilà François
de crier victoire on attend quand même
l'arbitrage d'Elizabeth borne la
première ministre elle est présente à
Guidel au sein des centres
oui elle a quitté le rendez-vous des
centrismes effectivement à la fin un
discours alors on a essayé de lire entre
les lignes on aurait bien aimé qu'elle
livre l'arbitrage mais c'est pas encore
le cas elle a parlé de dialogue constant
de débat serein d'ouverture pour les
élus du MoDem ça penche donc vers
l'hypothèse d'une plus grande
concertation avec une réforme globale
mais ce qu'on peut retenir c'est qu'elle
a surtout mis en garde contre les
divisions les divisions internes à la
majorité écoutez la première ministre
nous devons agir en confiance tout se
dire entre nous utiliser les nombreux
espaces de dialogue que nous avons
construit avant de pouvoir parler d'une
seule voix en étant solidaire de nos
décisions collectives nous formons une
majorité unie et nous ne réussirons que
si nos trois groupes parlementaires font
bloc
ce que je peux vous dire Myriam c'est
contre Elisabeth borne et François
Bayrou bah le climat était un petit peu
frisquet comme le temps ici en Bretagne
alors la première ministre elle est
restée un peu discutée avec les élus du
MoDem elle est ensuite rentrée à Paris à
la rendez-vous demain pour le déjeuner
avec le président de la République au
menu les retraites évidemment alors pour
les députés de la majorité qu'ils soient
pour ou contre tel ou telle solution ce
qu'il nous disent de manière unanime
c'est qu'il faut trancher trancher vite
puisqu'on ne parle plus que de la forme
et pas du fond merci beaucoup Elsa mon
Agava ça vous manque pas du tout je suis
très content de pas être vraiment ce
bazar adresse semblable et je le reçois
bien du courage pour en sortir la seule
manière serait quand même de débrancher
la prise de cette réforme des retraites
et passer à autre chose on parle
beaucoup de ballons d'essai c'est
quelque chose qu'on faisait l'idée on
lance quelque chose on voit comment ça
réagit ou ça peut être une manœuvre
véritable boomerang qu'on se prend dans
la figure en général
j'ai reçu on verra ce qu'il en est mais
on a l'impression qu'on atterrit en
douceur vers vers une solution de
consensus sans passage en force Yanis
roder bonsoir bonsoir ravi de vous
accueillir dans la bande des affranchis
vous l'enseignant en Seine-Saint-Denis
avec été choqué cette semaine par
l'agression d'une enseignante à Paris
par le frère d'une élève à qui à qui
l'enseignante avait demandé d'enlever
son voile au moment d'ailleurs où
l'actualité iranienne nous rappelle que
les femmes là-bas brûlent leur voile et
manifeste sans se voilent elles se
battent pour la liberté vous nous dites
que nous aussi en France on a quoi des
Gardiens de la Révolution islamique oui
Myriam cette professeur a peut-être
vendredi dernier échappé au pire grâce à
l'intervention rapide des forces de
l'ordre dévouer à ces élèves elle avait
décidé d'organiser une sortie à la
Bibliothèque historique de la Ville de
Paris elle a demandé une élève d'enlever
son signe religieux rien que de très
banal en réalité
elle a fait appliquer la loi elle a fait
appliquer la loi la loi du 15 mars 2004
qui proscrit les signes religieux
ostensibles à l'école et donc aussi
durant les sorties pédagogiques mais la
jeune femme refuse et téléphone à sa
famille son frère demande alors à parler
à l'enseignante en guise de dialogue ce
sont des menaces qui sont proférées par
ce jeune homme de 22 ans jugez-en plutôt
je vais venir te défoncer tu vas voir ce
qu'il va t'arriver j'arrive
auraient-ils déclaré l'enseignante a
alors le bon réflexe elle prévient les
forces de l'ordre qui appréhende le
jeune homme alors en chemin
alors qu'est-ce qui veut dire cet
incident pour vous selon moi Myriam tout
d'abord il nous montre que nous avons à
faire à une partie de la jeunesse certes
très minoritaire il faut le rappeler
mais qui véhicule une vision absolutiste
de la religion c'est à dire que ces
jeunes vivent dans leur croyance et leur
plutôt vive leur croyances et leur
pratique comme un absolu absolument un
dépassable et tout entorse à ce qu'il
croit juste et vrai est impossible
l'institution scolaire sait gérer ces
situations là ou pas tout le travail
fait ces dernières années en effet
permis d'outillés les enseignants les
chefs d'établissement et à doté les
rectorats d'équipes valeur de la
République qui réagissent vraiment au
signalement qui leur sont faits
se tient ce même Myriam il tient à ce
que j'appellerais la stratégie de la
terreur cet enseignante veut faire
découvrir un lieu de culture à ses
élèves elle en récolte des menaces qui
sont pour le moins traumatisantes après
le drame de Samuel Paty dont tout le
monde se souvient la question qu'on peut
se poser et de savoir combien de temps
les professeurs vous obtiendront si ces
situations se multiplient vont-ils
continuer à signaler les entorses au
principe de laïcité s'ils savent qu'ils
risquent derrière menace lynchage sur
les réseaux sociaux voir pire au-delà du
risque de voir des professeurs baisser
les bras qui voudra exercer un métier
potentiellement dangereux alors pour
assurer les enseignants et encourager de
futurs vocations le soutien qu'apporte
l'éducation nationale et l'État en
général est primordial rappelons que
durant sa garde à vue le jeune homme a
posé les termes du débat il aurait ainsi
dit aux policiers si quelqu'un touche ou
demande à ma sœur d'enlever son voile
dans la rue je le tue
nous savons aujourd'hui qu'il faut
prendre au sérieux les discours de ceux
qui se rêvent en gardien de la
Révolution islamique l'école de la
République nous parle toujours des
dynamiques à l'oeuvre dans la société il
faut y prêter attention
ce sont des actes de violence qui
existent mais sont minoritaires Yanis
l'a dit mais ils existent on a des
enseignants qui les rapportent on a des
comités de la laïcité qui veille à tout
relayer tous les signalements il y a une
prise de conscience on disait à votre
avis on a la laïcité j'espère pas trop
tardive mais la seule réponse ça doit
être l'extrême fermeté de la police et
de la justice et puis évidemment
l'éducation et pour cela il faut que les
professeurs et les moyens de faire leur
travail sur le plan pédagogique mais
c'est pas à eux de faire la police dans
la rue parce que c'est comportements
sont délictueux et méritent que les
forces de l'ordre sont saisissent merci
beaucoup merci pour cette histoire
d'école bien sombre mais vous reviendrez
nous raconterez
merci à vous merci Isabelle à très vite
Gaspard gonzer êtes-vous encore de
gauche il répond oui mais ça va au-delà
c'est à la fois de la coulisse et aussi
une réflexion critique sur cette gauche
qu'il veut reconstruire à demain tout de
suite votre soirée documentaire avec
Jean-Pierre facial bien sûr rester avec
nous
[Musique]